donde vivimos también han robado
demasiado y hoy en día como está la
delincuencia yo creo que ahora es como
casi una necesidad tener una un arma
dentro de la casa
aquí la enseñan a manipular lo que el
tema teórico entonces a medida que le
van haciendo clases y uno viene a
entrenar he mejorado la puntería la
manipulación la forma de tomar el arma
Entonces es totalmente diferente y uno
pierde el miedo también porque Yo
anteriormente yo le tenía terror o sea
cuando no ocurrió el tema del portonazo
a nosotros nos apuntaron y en verdad yo
aquí en shock y ya después no queríamos
salir de noche
[Música]
del 2020 al 23 esto ha crecido de manera
rápida partimos con muy poquito autos al
principio y
la escalada de violencia ha ido
progresivamente aumentando el nivel de
fuego que tenemos en las calles en Chile
es difícil pensar que eso se vaya a
acabar de manera muy rápida y por lo
tanto los los clientes buscan Cómo
proteger tanto
a ellos a su familia o a sus
trabajadores
[Música]